[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar mastering basic techniques for
cancer cell culture i am matt ashton of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermal fisher scientific
for everyone who is attending the
webinar today we know that understanding
cancer cell culture
is essential for the life of your work
gibco galaxy tour webinar has the aim of
connecting you to our gibko experts who
will share their knowledge and
experience to help you master modeling
the complexities of cancer in your
research
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
brittany ballhaus research and
development scientist at thermal fisher
scientific
brittany you may now begin your
presentation
all right thanks matt hi everyone i'm
honored to be able to present some of
the basics of cancer cell culture to you
today
as well as some of the lessons i've
learned from my experience doing cancer
research over the years
here's an overview of the presentation
today
first we'll start with why it is
important to study cancer
and why there is so much work yet to be
done in preventing and treating cancer
next we'll go over the hallmarks of
cancer and what's all bottles and tools
to consider as you begin your line of
research
finally we'll dive into how you can use
those cells and tools to model the
hallmarks of cancer in vitro
and we'll end with some resources that
may be helpful for your cancer research
so let's dive in
first just to ground us a little bit
why is it important to study cancer
well although we made some real strides
in recent decades and reducing the
incidence of
some forms of cancer
with regulation of carcinogenic
materials and vaccinations for instance
and reduced deaths by catching cases
early with screening recommendations
cancers still accounted for nearly one
in sec six
deaths worldwide in 2020
if we take breast cancer as an example
there were over 2 million cases recorded
in 2020
even though we now have a better
understanding of genetic mutations like
the bracha gene that can predispose one
to breast cancer
and have tools like mammograms for
regular screening
there were still an estimated
684
996 deaths
due to breast cancer in 2020
so why is cancer so difficult to prevent
or even cure
well cancer is unique to each individual
that is to say once one patient's cancer
is inherently different than another
another patient's cancer
this is because cancer arises from each
patient's own cells
you see there is a lot of cell turnover
in the human body
and each time a cell proliferates there
is a risk that something
a risk of something going wrong with the
genetic code
usually if something goes wrong and the
dna is corrupted
that cell will self-destruct or be
destroyed by immune cells
if the mutation occurs in a very
specific gene however
the cell may not trigger that
self-destruction process and may
be able to evade immune surveillance
this gives that corrupted cancer cell a
chance to divide and acquire new
mutations this may lead to uncontrolled
growth of the mutated cells and
progression of cancer
in addition to the cell turnover the
series of events may also be triggered
by external stressors
as seen in the video here
here you can see that the external
stress stressor can trigger a point
mutation or chromosomal rearrangement
either of which can trigger
tumor growth
so let's next go over the key features
of cancer that drive malignancy
these hallmarks of cancer were outlined
in a landmark paper by hanahan and
weinberg in
and they updated and extended their list
in another publication in 2011.
these papers have become must reads for
new cancer researchers and i'm happy to
report that an overview of these
hallmarks can be found in
thermo fisher scientific cancer cell
culture basics handbook
now we've already spoken about
about a few of these on the previous
slide
namely resisting cell death sustained
proliferative signaling evading gross
oppressors genome instability and
mutation
and evading immune destruction
others include
replicative immortality
tumor-promoting
inflammation and evading immune
destruction
and the rest we'll discuss in more
detail later in the talk
these include inducing angiogenesis
invasion and metastasis and deregulating
cellular energetics
each of these hallmarks is right for
ripe for scientific inquiry
and could be studied singularly or
jointly with other hallmarks
with cancer cell culture
and of course the first step to
investigating one of these hallmarks
with cell culture is choosing the right
cell model
there are many things to consider when
you're choosing which cancer cells you
would like to culture for your research
for example which cancer type or types
are you interested in
do you need several lines lines to
capture various subtypes within a
specific cancer indication
are you interested in localized cancer
metastatic disease or the progression
from one to the other
what cells have the specific gene or
protein expression that you need for
testing your potential therapy
it is important that you think through
which cancer cells best address your
research questions
and remember that several different cell
models are often needed
these panels of cancer cells are popular
for investigating several cancer types
at once
several subtypes with
within a cancer indication or to
represent patient-to-patient
heterogeneity for a given cancer type
this is an example of one such panel
these four cell lines represent four
different stages of breast cancer
progression from the same patient
the panel was generated from a
non-malignant breast cell line named
mcf-10a that was intentionally
transformed with a mutant
ha ras gene to create another cell lined
named
mcf-10at
the mcf 10a t line models the
pre-malignant stage of cancer
the mcf10at cells were then clonally
selected
until a line which represented the pure
comedo-ductal carcinoma in situ
subtype was found this line was named
mcf10dcis.com
finally the mcf 1080t line was also
serially passaged through mice
until a highly invasive metastatic
subtype was established and the
resulting cell line was named mcf10ca1
thus the progression from non-malignant
to localized disease to metastatic
disease all within a genetic background
can be bottled with this cell line panel
such a panel could be especially useful
in seeing how well a therapy is
selectively targeting highly or
selectively targeting cancer cells for
example
another thing to consider is whether or
not you'd like to utilize cancer cell
lines
or primary cells for your can for your
cancer research
studies using cancer cell lines are most
common as they provide a few key
advantage advantages
namely that they are easy to scale up to
get a large number of cells
for your study
and you can also culture them for many
passages and don't have to keep
isolating cells from tuber tissue every
few weeks
there is also a huge publication
record that you can reference to help
with your study and to contextualize
your research for publication
however the downside is that cancer cell
lines which have been in culture for
decades can be hypermutated as compared
to freshly isolated tumor cells
and thus no longer represent the patient
tumor from which they were derived
primary cells on the other hand by
definition come straight from the
patient tumor and are therefore far more
physiologically relevant
the major con to using primary cells
however is that generally they can only
be
cultured for short periods of time
believe it or not the success rate for
establishing a new cell line is still
relatively low even though these are
cancer cells
therefore you'd have to keep procuring
tumor tissue
or freshly isolated cancer cells
regularly to continue your primary cell
studies
one emerging cell
model type that bridges the gap between
these cancer
cell lines and primary cells
are our cancer are known as the cancer
organized model or tumoroids
these are freshly patient derived models
that are grown in 3d and may be cultured
for a relatively long period of time as
compared to primary cells grown in 2d
the culture method for these can be
relatively difficult but it may be worth
it for your research if you desire high
physiological relevance
one final note
rather than choosing one or the other
these can be used in tandem or
sequentially with your research starting
with cell lines to narrow the scope then
moving to primary cell culture later
for later studies for instance
and tumerics are not the only cells that
can be cultured in 3d of course cell
lines can also be cultured in 3d either
fully encapsulated in a basement
membrane extracts like gel tracks or
major gel or in suspension
but should you culture your cells in 3d
well it depends
both 2d and 3d culture have pros and
cons
2d culture is more widely utilized as it
is the easier of the two culture methods
it has a larger publication record with
which to contextualize one's research
and can be easier to monitor for
response to experimental conditions by
imaging for instance
however because adherent cell lines grow
in 2d
in a monolayer the cells are
experiencing a decidedly
non-physiological environment
they are attached to a plastic substrate
that is much stiffer than tissues in the
body
the cells are only interacting with each
other at the edges in two dimensions
and all the cells have free access to
nutrients in cell culture medium
cells in 3d on the other hand have
three dimensional cell cell interactions
do not interact much if at all
with a relatively stiff substrate
and the cells will have different access
to the nutrients from the medium
depending on where they are located
within the spheroid of cancer cells
however 3d cultures are notoriously
difficult to dissociate
and often
often utilize specialized protocols and
equipment for imaging
therefore depending on your research
question you may or may not want to
undertake 3d culture
or you may want to start with 2d culture
and progress to 3d at a later point
of course paramount to any of this
research is the type of medium that you
are feeding your cells
it is very important that you think
through
both the type of the basal medium
that you would like to use as well as
the supplements that you are planning on
using
and it really depends on your cell model
and your research question
the scientific literature is a good
place to start to find a medium but you
may want to adjust it for your specific
experiments
for instance if you are utilizing
estrogen receptor positive breast cancer
cell lines
you may want to use phenol red free
basal medium since phenol red is a weak
estrogen mimic
similarly a specialty fetal bovine serum
namely charcoal stripped fps
which has been treated to remove
hormones may also be useful for
estrogen-related studies
similarly you must carefully choose the
culture vessel or cell culture plastics
that are right for your purpose
first consider if you need your cells to
adhere or not this will help you choose
between non-treated or tissue
culture-treated vessels
of course you will also need to consider
if you are just scaling up your cultures
or if you are performing high throughput
experiments
if the latter health high throughput
meaning number of conditions or
replicates etc
do you need
also which type of assays will you be
utilizing are you looking at
fluorescence
you may want black wall plates
are you growing spheroids you may want
to try very low attachment plates like
nucleon sphera
and cell culture insert plate systems
have a variety of uses that we'll get
into in just a little bit
now back to our hallmarks of cancer
since we've gone over the cell models
and tools you may need for your cancer
research let's discuss how you can model
angiogenesis invasion and metastasis and
deregulating cellular energetics in
vitro
starting with angiogenesis
angiogenesis refers to the growth of new
blood vessels
this is key for cancer progression as
tumors can only grow so big without
being vascularized
if a tumor does not have its own blood
supply
running throughout
the cells at the center of the tumor
will start to die as nutrients will not
be able to reach them
therefore as seen in the video when
there is a small tumor forming or
breaking off from the primary site
it will secrete angiogenic growth
factors like vegf
in order to attract endothelial cells to
proliferate and infiltrate into the
tumor
thus allowing it to continue to grow
angiogenesis is also key for another
hallmark mark of cancer metastasis
as the tumor cells utilize blood vessels
to migrate from the primary site to the
to distant tissues for colonization
therefore cancer cell endothelial cell
interactions are very important to study
these types of studies can be done with
cell culture in several ways
for modeling angiogenesis in vitro
endothelial cells must be cultured with
an extracellular matrix mimic
or basement membrane extracts like
geltrex
in order to form
tube-like structures and networks
if you'd like to study the impact of
secreted
factor crosstalk between endothelial
cells and cancer cells
this can be accomplished with co-culture
and cell culture inserts
one could also look at
more direct contact by embedding
endothelial cells and cancer cells
together and an intuition mimic
more complex models may incorporate the
spatial relationship between cancer
cells within a tissue and endothelial
cells
lining a patent vessel which is best
modeled with microfluidic devices
wherein
we're in fluid flow reminiscent of blood
flow can also be accomplished
although angiogenesis and metastasis can
be observed in these complex
microfluidic devices
transient endothelial migration can also
be observed in a simpler setup
and we'll discuss that now
as cancer progresses cancer cells can
invade the local environment near the
primary tumor site and in some cases
migrate across the endothelial cell
barrier into the blood vessels in a
process called imtravisation
once inside the vasculature the cancer
cells can be carried to distant sites
far from the primary tumor and
extravasate or cross the endothelial
cell lining again
once more to colonize that distance site
and form a secondary tumor
the process of intravasation
extravasation and colonization is called
metastasis in the video you can see
cancer cells break away from the
extracellular matrix at the primary
tumor site and travis ate and
extravasate
to the secondary tumor site
invasion and metastasis can be studied
with cell culture in several ways
one of the simplest methods is the wound
healing assay where if you scratch a
monolayer of cells with a pipette tip
and see how long it takes to close the
gap in the monolayer
the rate at which the wound closes is
related to how migratory or invasive the
cells are either due to the cell type or
the condition to which they were exposed
in the figure below
we showed
show the increased wound healing
response of breast cancer cells with
exposure to heat stable basic fgf as
compared to a low sarah medium condition
a far more complex way to investigate
invasion and metastasis is with
microfluidic devices
where an endothelial cells can be seeded
to align a channel with
within a cancer cell laden extracellular
matrix mimic
and cancer cells can be observed
extravazating within the device
a classic and more widely used method
for modeling invasion however utilizes
cell culture inserts so let's take a
closer look at this approach
here we have diagrams showing the
classic setup for migration and invasion
experiments
for those that may not be familiar with
them cell culture inserts are
essentially smaller wells that fit
inside the larger wells of a well plate
this forms an upper chamber and a lower
chamber where media conditions or cells
can be seeded separately but can also
interact the interaction can occur
because the cell culture inserts have a
porous membrane for a bottom instead of
solid plastic
therefore for migration experiments
cancer cells can be seeded in the upper
chamber and a soluble factor that
attracts the cancer cells to migrate
towards it
known as a chemoattractant can be added
to the bottom chamber
if the cells are invasive or metastatic
they will migrate through the pores to
the underside of the membrane
where the number of migratory cells can
be counted
for invasion experiments the setup is
identical but before the cells are
seeded onto the forest membrane the
membrane is first coated in a basement
membrane extract like gel tracks
this adds yet another barrier that
invasive or metastatic cells must cross
to reach the chemoattractant on the
other side of the membrane
so let's look at an example of this in
action
for this experiment non-metastatic mcf7
cells and highly metastatic mda and b231
breast cancer cell lines were used
the chemo attractant was 10 fps
which was added only to the bottom
chamber
and the top chamber the cells proceeded
in serum free medium
after 20 hours the cells on the
underside of the porous membrane were
counted and the percent of cells that
migrated
was calculated
you can see that in both the migration
setup without gel tracks and the
invasion setup with gel trucks
a much higher percentage of the
metastatic mda mb231 cells cross the
membrane in response to fps as compared
to the non-metastatic mcf7 cell line
also interesting is that for the
migration setup
close to 90 percent of the mda and b231
cells made it across the membrane
versus only about 70 percent that made
it across and the invasion setup
this demonstrates the additional barrier
to migration that gel the gel trex
coding provides
so now that we understand the basics of
modeling cancer cell endothelial cell
interactions and invasion and metastasis
in the lab
let's take a look at a more complex
example
with this experiment an
extravasation event is modeled
if you look at the pains of the figure
from left to right the model gets more
and more complex
in panel a you just have the metastatic
prostate cell line pc3 the cells are
stained blue
and that are seated in the upper chamber
and the same medium
seated above and below the membrane
as there is no chemo attractant on the
bottom in the bottom chamber there is
little migration
next in panel b serum containing medium
was put in the into the bottom chamber
and just like in the previous example
the serum induced the pc3 cells to
migrate across the membrane
in panel c
instead of serum containing medium
in the bottom chamber bone cells known
as osteocytes were seeded in the bottom
and their secreted factors acted as a
chemoattractant to induce the pc3 cells
to migrate across the membrane
finally
in panel d you have the full
extravasation model
endothelial cells which are stained red
are seated on the underside of the
membrane to form a barrier
representative of the wall of a blood
vessel
again the osteocytes are used as the
chemoattractant
and amazingly you can see by the blue
on top of the red in the bottom image
that not only do the pc3 cells migrate
across the membrane but also across the
endothelial cell monolayer in response
to the soluble factors that the
osteocytes are secreting
this experiment is also a fantastic
example of how cell culture inserts can
be used first co-culture experiments
with a variety of cell types
the final hallmark of cancer we will
discuss today is deregulating cellular
energetics
this is a fairly complex topic but in
short
most normal cells and tissues utilize
mitochondria to get energy and only
switch to a secondary method of
metabolism known as glycolysis
if oxygen is in low supply because
glycolysis is a relatively inefficient
way to get energy
well in the 1920s otto warburg and
colleagues observed that cancer cells
were using far more glucose than the
surrounding normal cells they realize
that cancer cells often utilize
glycolysis to meet the high energy
requirements for tumor growth even in
oxygen-rich environments
this phenomenon was termed the warburg
effect
and it is a true hallmark of cancer
the increased glucose uptake of cancer
cells is even used in clinical imaging
to diagnose cancer
and monitor tumor response to therapy
cancer cell
metabolism not only has implications for
tumor growth but also responds to
anti-cancer drugs and is therefore very
important to model in a physiologically
relevant way in vitro
one tool that is very exciting to
accomplish this is
human plasma like medium or hplm
hplm was modeled after human plasma and
therefore is
more physiologically relevant than
traditional cell culture medium
for instance regarding the glucose which
was so critical to the warburg effect
hplm has about a third of the
concentration of glucose of other
traditional media formulations
as you might imagine this can have a
major impact on the metabolism of cancer
cells and their response to anti-cancer
drugs
in the data shown here you can see that
it took about 175 times the amount of
the cytotoxic compound styrosporine
to kill the same number of cells in
traditional dmemem medium as an hpl
lambdian
this may be explained by the unique
metabolic profile that cells in hplm
have versus traditional media
as shown in this next slide
for this study we have spheroid models
of three different cancer cell lines
each line was grown in three different
conditions
a traditional cell culture medium plus
regular fps
hplm plus regular fps and hplm plus
stylized fbs
you can see by the bar graphs that
depending on the media formulation and
the type of serum chosen
the cancer
cell metabolism as measured by atp
production is significantly different
therefore it is very important to
consider the formulation in which you
are growing or assaying yourselves
the closer we can match an invivo-like
environment to study cancer in the lab
the better our in-vitro results will
hold up when translated from the lab
bench to the bedside
so that wraps up our overview of how to
model in vitro
three of the hallmarks of cancer
outlined by hanahan and weinberg
hopefully this will inspire you to delve
into studying one or more of these
hallmarks in your own research
cancer is so common so complex and such
a difficult problem to solve
we can certainly use all the help we can
get to better prevent and treat this
awful disease in the years to come
for more information on the hallmarks of
cancer
how to choose your cancer cell models
and culture method
please check out our cancer cell culture
basics handbook at thermofisher.com
cancer cell culture
we also have a wealth of other valuable
information there including cancer cell
culture protocols and our
cell culture heroes some on our series
which is wonderful
and i invite you to check it out
i really appreciate your attendance and
attention today
and i'll be happy to take any questions
we have from the audience
thank you
thank you brittany for providing such
wonderful insights on her cancer cell
research we'll now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
on your slide on invasion and metastasis
i saw that heat stable basic fgf was
used why is heat stable basic fgf chosen
rather than native basic fgf
yeah that's a that's a great question so
native
human fgf
bfgf rapidly loses bioactivity at
standard culture conditions like 37
degrees celsius
this means that more frequent media
changes and more protein is required to
maintain biological activity
now heat stable fgf
is
specially engineered to be thermostable
and to retain bioactivity at
physiological temperatures
it has more than 90 sequence homology to
the native protein
but it has greater than
80 bioactivity after 72 hours at 37
degrees c so it's a very cool product
highly recommend heat staple
bfgf
thank you
the next question we have
just came through is which cancer cell
lines can i grow in gibco human plasma
like medium
yeah also also a very good question
so we've tested and shown compatibility
of hplm with a variety of cancer cell
lines representing
many different cancer types
breast cancer cell lines like mcf7 and
mda and b231
of course hela cells lincap a549 and
even jerkat
cells
use the hblm just like you would your
typical basal medium you supplement it
with fbs
and then you're good to go you don't
have to adapt it from your normal medium
at all
um even beyond cancer we've shown that
primary natural killer cells can also be
grown in hplm
so if you're interested in cancer immune
co-culture studies you can utilize hplm
there as well
we do have a full list of all the cancer
cell lines and other cell types that
we've tested
on our website
great thank you and looks like we have
time for just one more question here
i've noticed that thermal fissure offers
a variety of cell culture inserts for
invasion and migration studies
how do i choose which one to order yeah
yeah you have to be careful so
the biggest difference in the cell
culture inserts is the pore size
so different applications and cell types
require different pore sizes
the first step is to determine what pore
size you need for your for your study of
interest
uh if it's a smaller pore size like 0.4
microns
this would be for applications where you
don't want the cells to migrate through
the pores so this would be just for
co-culture or transport type studies for
just secreted factors or going above and
below the membrane
uh the larger pore sizes like eight
microns it's what's recommended for
studies where you would like to see the
cells migrate
chemotaxis invasion studies
i would recommend checking out the
application notes on our website and
that should help guide you into which
cell culture insert product would be
appropriate for your study of interest
okay
well this wraps up our git code galaxy
tour webinar today i would like to thank
brittany for sharing her cell culture
experience in cancer research which i'm
sure will be very beneficial to all of
the cancer cell researchers a big thank
you to our audience for joining us today
and submitting interesting questions for
those questions that we are unable to
answer today we'll follow up with an
answer via email
we hope all of you have gained more
knowledge today
that will help you enhance your lab
skills
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermal fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to ask any
everyone any and everyone to take our
survey at the end of this webinar
just so you can tell us your feedback
when you complete the survey you will be
entered into a drawing to win a gibco
exclusive lego set and a featured
product from this webinar this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
hope to see you again for our next gibco
galaxy tour webinar focusing on genome
editing in october thank you
and goodbye for now
you